[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk with the king
now that Pacquiao a Jim Brown has summed
it all up it was how I said it was gonna
go you know we sort of fight
we saw Pacquiao always give well you
can't say always give 110 percent well
you know the guy always tries you know
and if something is being successful he
doesn't get downtrodden he pushes
forward
what Adrien Broner we saw like I said
you know was going to try to set traps
and in fact yeah I fell into these traps
he then he would be more inclined to
engage and let his hands fly but if
Pacquiao is attacking Adrien Broner goes
into a defense mode and you know he runs
from any altercation that could
embarrass him but this is something that
we knew already and we knew that these
individuals is going to perform to their
natural instincts that they're veterans
in this game and expecting them to be
anything other than what they displayed
on the last Saturday would be a farce or
would be fraudulent in your perception
of what was going to happen but this I
didn't do a results show because it was
nothing mind-blowing first of all
shout-out to the card every fight on
that car besides the main event fight
was a fight of guts and glory there was
a display of willingness humbleness
mastery in your craft desire to be great
a desire to fulfill the promise that you
have given the crowd a desire to be that
gladiator when you step into those ropes
that squared circle is sacred and shout
out to those fighters on that night that
displayed that willingness and that love
for that and showed the respect for that
squared circle that we earned the right
to fight and get paid for because don't
ever believe that gladiators were
getting paid before you know the history
the long history in prize fighting in
combat and it goes very far and it all
starts with pride and ego now I'm going
to get to the elephant inside the room
the elephant in the room is Adrien
Broner at what point in time is just so
worth that price that is uh being
extrapolated and extracted from you at
what point in time is yes so worth the
buffoonery in culinary you must really
start to believe the character care that
you've made of yourself you have fans
and they are diehard because they are
looking for what you possess but what
they don't see is what you don't really
possess is that fighting spirit that
fight is hard you're what we called it
just enough that a person that will do
just enough not to lose just to win and
if the opportunity presents itself
they're gonna go for that price but they
won't risk what they built and I
understand brother I've seen your
struggle you've stated numerous times
that you have came from nothing so that
nothing haunts you in that huh nothing
prevents you from being great that fear
of where you came from scares you to
death because you feel that the
buffoonery in corner we will keep you in
a secure place what is made on sand will
never be solid and you have built your
legacy on sand and it's crumbling in
front of your very eyes you got on
national TV you've made a mockery of my
sport you've made a mockery of yourself
cooling and buffoon a never living up to
your words never laying it all out then
at the end of the show betraying
yourself in a manner that is unbecoming
of a former champion a proud King it was
a display on a level of disbelief but I
understand you are in the trappings that
you have made for yourself now this is
not an indictment upon you this is an
indictment on the sport and the people
that around you that have allowed this
to continue to the point that you've
seen success and anytime you reward
someone for inappropriate behavior and
you got paid and then they will continue
to do the same inappropriate behavior
and it will escalate because they want
more of that reward that they received
I expected that
I expected this Adrien Broner on his
first pay-per-view to come out and give
you everything that he had in the tank
he left it on the floor and when he lost
all he won he raised his hand or he held
his hand high and told the crowd I'll be
back
what you didn't do that so we all know
what you did I don't really think you
recover from this I believe this is that
actually the crux that sticks inside
your craw and will stay with you on to
the fight tonight we have Keith Thurman
versus socially clean Lopez and it's a
good fight for Keith Thurman Keith
Thurman has been off for two years
people said that he lost a desire to
fight I believe that the boy fought for
so long and he made it to a place where
he fought strong fights back to back to
back yeah I understand
he fought um Danny Garcia he fought
Shawn Porter he fought the fights that
he was supposed to fight and he won
these fights and he earned some time off
but during this time off he got injured
during these fights and stuff and he
took a break and he looks recharged
revitalized and ready to fight and came
in at 146 junior welterweight title us
obsolete those saying oh Selita looks
determined host Alito is a fighter who
is going to give you the best that he
has going into this fight he always lays
it out there when loser draw he's a
man's man and makes no excuses I I
expect Keith Thurman to be into a good
dust-up to get some rounds and maybe by
the eighth round if not you know like it
might go 12 rounds he might just go to
get the rounds just to test his shoulder
but you say you know from the eighth
round you're gonna start to see the wear
and tear on all Selita and might break
down I've seen a focus on cielito he
gave up a fight earlier
in the it's just to secure this fight so
maybe this fight I don't know you know
this is a very precarious fight but my
prediction is Keith Thurman by stoppage
or knockout by the 9th 10th round could
be the 8th round I know about the 8th
round you're gonna start to see the wear
and tear on hosts Alito hopefully the
man has everything in a tank and he can
get to the 12th round because you know
he's earned this fight to fight the
champion and it's good to see Keith
Thurman back the division needed him
back because he's the missing piece
while all these fighters is actually
fighting out here have a nice round
robin between him
Errol spin saw blood Crawford you know
Shawn Porter is in the mix Danny Garcia
still there then you'll probably get
Adrien Broner up there to fight Danny
Garcia something of that nature you know
somebody that can actually push this boy
boxing is great don't give up on a sport
because of something that you saw last
week that made you turn away also
remember you have body jack last week
fighting what a split decided the front
of his head like I've never seen from
the seventh round on to the 12th round
that man finished that fight that was
true blood and guts shout out to a true
warrior that night you got fight of the
night that night you supposed to get
Adrienne Broaddus purse my hat's off to
you sir unsurmountable odds facing a
fold that is younger stronger bigger
more equipping yourself with a deficit
that it just seemed unconquered bull the
corner
could it be the look delusional at the
moment your corner kept you in the game
and get belief in the corner is true
that's a true bond between men he didn't
allow you to quit on yourself and he
didn't quit on you so my hats off to
Badu Jack who was our the actual real
winner over the last week's Pacquiao
Brona fight and shout-out to everyone
that tuned in because it did 440,000
buys on pay-per-view it was great what i
don't want to see is Pacquiao fight
these young guys anymore get the Floyd
fight and move on this is combat talk
with the king
hope to see y'all next week when we got
a barnburner
[Applause]
[Music]